GOOD EVERYONE FIVE AND- WELCOME
TO THIS MORNING'S HEARING AT THE
ASSEMBLY'S ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE
I'M VERY BRIEFLY BEFORE WE BEGIN
I'LL GO OVER A FEW STEPS. I THAT
WE'RE TAKING TO PRESERVE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE AND TO
ENSURE THE PUBLIC'S ACCESS TO
THE DISCUSSION TO ENSURE THAT
MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA AND PUBLIC
HAVE ACCESS TO OUR PROCEEDINGS
TODAY THIS HEARING WILL BE
STREAMED ON THE ASSEMBLY'S
WEBSITE AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC CAN PROVIDE TESTIMONY. IN-PERSON IN ROOM FOUR THREE SEVEN
OR VIA THE PHONE I FOR THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM FOR ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC PRESENT IN
THE HEARING ROOM PLEASE NOTE
THAT WE ARE REQUIRING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE SCENE PLEASE FOLLOW THE
DIRECTIONS OF OUR START
SERGEANTS AND POSTED GUIDANCE. I
IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL
I IN THE ROOM I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. OFFER PHONE
TESTIMONY FOR ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WILL BE PROVIDING
COMMENTS VIA TELEPHONE WE ARE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THE HEARING IS. 877-272-8451 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN I
PLEASE CALL IN WHEN THE AUTHOR
OF THE BILL YOU WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT ON BEGINS THEIR
PRESENTATION OR WHEN THE SECOND
WITNESS ON THE INFORMATIONAL
ITEM BEGINS HER PRESENTATION. I
THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL
THEN GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO BE PLACEDIN THE QUEUE.
AND LASTLY I DO YOU WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE ASSEMBLY HAS
EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO COMMITTEE AND
FLOOR PROCEEDINGS OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS. WE DO WANT TO ENSURE
THAT ALL VOICES ARE HEARD
HOWEVER CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT AT THE HEARING.
IS PROHIBITED I THANK YOU IN
ADVANCE FOR YOUR COOPERATION. UP
WITH THAT AS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PETRIE-NORRIS
PRESIDENT PATTERSON YOUR GREAT.
LACKING HERE AND DINNER.
RODRIGUEZ FONG THERE. ALL RIGHT
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND- WE'RE
READY TO BEGIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLAME. WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OVER HALF OF ALL
RENTERS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
CONSIDERED RENT BURDENED MEANING
THAT THEY SPEND OVER A THIRD OF
THEIR INCOME ON RENT AND ARE
LESS ABLE TO PAY FOR OTHER
ESSENTIALS LIKE HEALTH CARE FOOD
AND TRANSPORTATION IN TWENTY
NINETEEN GOVERNOR NEWSOM
DIRECTED STATE AGENCIES TO TAKE
A MORE ACTIVE ROLE IN ADDRESSING
THE HOUSING CRISIS BY
FACILITATING HOUSING PRODUCTION
ON STATE OWNED PROPERTIES. AB
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY NINE BUILDS
ON THE GOVERNOR'S EFFORTS BY
ESTABLISHING A PILOT PROJECT TO
LOOK AT UNDER UTILIZED STATE
PROPERTIES THAT CAN ACCOMMODATE
BOTH AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
ESSENTIAL STATE SERVICES THE
BILL IDENTIFIES THREE SPECIFIC
SITES THAT ARE BOTH OUTDATED AND
LARGE ENOUGH TO ACCOMMODATE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING NAMELY THE DMV FIELD
OFFICES IN SANTA MONICA CULVER
CITY AND HOLLYWOOD TWO OF THE
THREE ARE LOCATED IN MY DISTRICT
. THE HAND OUT IN FRONT OF YOU
INCLUDES AN AERIAL VIEW OF THE
SITES AND SOME. DATA AS YOU CAN
SEE ALL THREE SITES TOTAL MORE
THAN SIX ACRES OF LAND A TOTAL
OF OVER FOUR FOUR FOOTBALL
FIELDS ARE CLOSE TO TRANSIT. AND
ARE SURROUNDED BY OTHER
COMMERCIAL AND RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES. THE THREE SITES HAVE
NOT HAD ANY MAJOR RENOVATIONS
SINCE THEY WERE FIRST
CONSTRUCTED. FIFTY OR MORE YEARS
AGO. WITH DM VIS RECENT EFFORTS
TO MODERNIZE THE DELIVERY OF
SERVICES AND REDUCE THE NEED FOR
IN PERSON VISITS LARGE UNDER
UTILIZED FIELD OFFICES MAY NOT
BE MOST EFFECTIVE AT PROVIDING
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIANS. BUT I
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THIS BILL
DOES NOT RESTRICT THE DMV IN
ANYWAY FROM DETERMINING HOW MUCH
SPACE THEY NEED ON EITHER OF THE
SITES- ON ANY OF THE SITES- THAT
WOULD BE THE SUBJECT OF THE
LEAST IT ONE OF THE SUBJECTS OF
THE LEASE NEGOTIATIONS. AB
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY NINE SIMPLY
pDIRECTS DGS IN CONSULTATION WITH
THE MV AND THE RESPECTIVE CITIES
TO WORK WITH A HOUSING DEVELOPER
TO CONSTRUCT NEW DMV FACILITIES
ALONGSIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AT
THESE SITES. THE STATE DOUG
WOULD LEASE THE PARCELS AT ZERO
COST TO THE DEVELOPER. IN
EXCHANGE THE HOUSING DEVELOPER
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CONSTRUCTION OF NEW DMV
FACILITIES AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS. THE MEASURE
ENSURES CUSTOMERS CAN CONTINUE
TO ACCESS SERVICES BY REQUIRING
DMV TO PROVIDE SERVICES AS THE
NEW FACILITIES ARE BEING
CONSTRUCTED. AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY NINE IS A PILOT PROJECT
TO HELP US RETHINK THE WAY WE
UTILIZE LIMITED STATE RESOURCES
TO TACKLE THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS. DMV WILL BE BETTER ABLE
TO ACCOMMODATE CUSTOMERS AT NEW
UPGRADED FACILITIES. THAT ARE
PAID FOR BY THE DEVELOPER AND
LOW INCOME FAMILIES WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THIS IS TRULY A WIN WIN FOR THE
STATE. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL TODAY IS SYLVIA SOLELY
STRAW REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA AND CRAIG BULLOCK
PLANNING DIRECTOR FOR
COUNCILMEMBER MITCH O'FARRELL IS
OFFICE. LOS ANGELES
COUNCILMEMBER MITCH O'FARRELL.
AND I OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE. FOR OUR
WITNESS THE CALL THAT WITH BE
SPACE SHOULD BE WHAT LIFE. OKAY
I'M- THE AT THE FIRST WITNESS
CAN GO AHEAD AND BEGIN PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE SOVIET POLICE
SHAUN BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA THE CITY WOULD LIKE
TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBERS BLOOM
FOR OFFERING THAT MEASURE ABOUT
A DECADE AGO THE CITY REALIZE
THE POTENTIAL AND IS CURRENTLY
UNDER USED PROPERTY. AND WE
OUTRAGE TO THE B. AND B. YOU
KNOW BEGIN A CONVERSATION ABOUT
HOW TO MAXIMIZE THE FLIGHT FIFTY
BELIEVE THAT THE DMV SITE IN
SANTA MONICA IS IDEALLY SITUATED
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING IT'S VERY
CLOSE TO TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
JOBS. TWO BLOCKS FROM AN ALLEY
METRO EXPO LINE TRAIN STATION
AND TWO BLOCKS FROM A PUBLIC
SCHOOL BUT BY THE REPRESENTS ONE
OF THE LARGEST PUBLICLY OWNED
SITES IN SANTA MONICA THAT COULD
ACCOMMODATE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHILE
BUILDING A NEW DMV FACILITY
FACILITY. THAT COULD BETTER
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF THE DMV
CUSTOMER PARTICULARLY NOW THAT A
LOT OF B. AND B. TRANSACTION CAN
BE AFFECT ON MINE. IN ADDITION
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE SITE
ALIGNS WITH THE CITY'S BROKERS.
OF USING PUBLICLY OWNED THE LAND
FOR AFFORDABLE SUCH AS THE
RECENT ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
UNIT PROJECT ON CITY OWNED LAND
NEAR CITY HALL IN ANOTHER
PROJECT THAT WILL CREATE A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY AFFORDABLE
UNITS ON THE HEAD OF THE CITY
OWNED PARKING STRUCTURE. FOR AND
YOU KNOW THIS COMES AT A
CRITICAL TIME BUDGET RIGHT. WITH
THE NEXT HOUSING ELEMENT CYCLE
OF THE CITY SANTA MONICA WRITTEN
IT. NINE UNITS SIXTY NINE OF
WHAT MIGHT I'M AT. VERY LEVEL.
DEBATED GET THE PUBLIC OWNED AT
BECAUSE BY THE BILL IS ONE WAY
TO HELP THE CITY BEACHES- AND WE
ARE THE COMMITTEE FOR A OF THE
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU I.
NEW AND- OPERATORS YOU CAN NOW
OPEN. THE ADELINE. FOR CRAIG
BOHL. THANK YOU SHOULD BE. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS CRAIG
BROADBAND THE PLANNING DIRECTOR
PRODUCTIONS WITH CITY
COUNCILMEMBER MITCH O'FARRELL OF
THE THIRTEENTH ISTRICT THE
THIRTEENTH COUNCIL DISTRICT OF
AN URBAN ENVIRONMENT WILL
CONSIST OF HOLLYWOOD WINDS ARE
SQUARE LARCHMONT ECHO PARK
ATWATER VILLAGE QUANTEL PARK AND
PORTIONS OF SILVER LAKE IT IS
ONE OF THE OLDEST AND DENTONS
PARTS OF THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
AND HAS TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND RESIDENTS. LIKE
THE REST OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES THE HOUSING COSTS ARE
SOME OF THE HIGHEST IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. IN THE- COUNCIL
DISTRICT THANK YOU LAND IT'S BUT
A YOU TO. PROPERLY ARE PLAN.
THIS ONE. WOULD REMEDY THAT BY
PROVIDING THE STATE OF THE CITY
WITH THE UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO
UPGRADE EXISTING DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES FACILITIES WHILE
PROVIDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON
UNDERUTILIZED PROPERTIES AND
URBAN AREAS. THE HOLLYWOOD DMB
IS LOCATED AT EIGHT OO THREE
CALL INS OVER AN ACRE AND A HALF
IN A GOOD LARGELY SURFACE
PARKING LOT. WITH A- WHAT WHAT
THEY THINK OF DON'T IN MIGHT
FEEL AGAINSTAFFORDABLE HOUSING
MEET THE NEED OF THEM TO THOSE.
TO READ ABOUT OF THE HOLLYWOOD
THE MBFI COST OF. WITH THE PLAN
USES AN WOOD BE AT LOOKED AT IN
THE NAY. WITHOUT DISPLAY ANY
PRESIDENT. OF THE NOT AMONG
ANYTHING RESOURCES. WHAT IS NOT
. IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OR URBAN.
IF CIRCLE PARKING LOT. THE
BOSTON GLOBE WHO DEPARTED BEGUN
GIVE A LIGHT IT THEM PROPERTY
THE CRECHE OF A PART HOUSING.
THE HOLLYWOOD ARE COLLECTIVE
LOCATED AT FIFTY FIVE TWENTY TWO
HOLLYWOOD. BECAUSE THE PRICE TWO
MILES FROM THE- DMB. HIS ALLIES
THE HE SAID OF METER TRUCK
PARKING COME THE- OF A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY YEARS THE BALLPARK
ACCORDING HOUSING. IN ADDITION
IT WILL PROVIDE A REVITALIZED
ARTS CENTER AND RETAIN THE LOCK
AND LOOKING. ART SPACE AND OUT
OF THE THEATER THAT WAS FUNDED
BY THE ACTORS. ALL WHAT REPLACE
MUCH PER FOR THE CLERK WILL BE.
THE PROJECT WILL TRULY TRANSFORM
NEIGHBORHOODS WHILE COOPER A
HEALTHY TOWARDS. IT'S THIRTY
THREE PUBLIC NUMBER OF PERIL THE
COURT. TWO POINT NINE AND THANK
SIMPLY PLAN PRISCILLA AND
CRICKETING HELPING ALL THE HOW
SHORTAGE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CAN. PUBLIC BY THE. AND THANK
YOU I MISTER BY. I THERE ARE
THERE A ADDITIONAL AND IN SOME.
HERE IN THE HEARING. HIS NINE
OPERATOR AT ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. AND IS A LEADER WHO
GENERALLY PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN
CURRENTLY MANNING TO.
SORRY OPERATOR DID YOU SAY THAT
THERE ARE. THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THERE'S NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE. OKAY THANK YOU CORRECT-
AND THAT WE DO NOT HAVE A
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
SIR ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
IS SEEN WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION.
I'M SURE MEMBERS OF MIKE MADIGAN
ON BEHALF THE- CALVARY STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL. WE ARE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED- WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
SOME LABOR PROTECTIONS IN THE
BILL. WE HAVE SHARED AMENDMENTS
WITH THE AUTHORS STAFF AND- HAVE
HAD DISCUSSIONS AS RECENTLY AS
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON. AND WE
SINCERELY HOPE THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE THOSE DISCUSSIONS AND
MAKE US A RESOLUTION ON THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU I.
pROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OPERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE WISHING
TO ADD TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION.
RELATED SHERMAN IF SO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THE. ZERO AND
CURRENTLY NOT ENGAGED YOU. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU OPERATOR I
QUESTIONS FROM NUMBERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY YEAH I'D I'VE
ALREADY ADDRESSED SOME OF OUR
CONCERNS WHAT MY CONCERNS ABOUT
THE DMV- SERVICES ASPECT THAT I
ALSO HAVE A QUESTION I'M HOPING
THAT YOU COULD I THINK I HEARD
BUT I'M NOT SURE THE ESTIMATION
OF HOW MANY HOUSING UNITS ARE
EXPECTED TO BE ACCOMPLISHED.
THROUGH THIS PROJECT BUT THE
BEST I CAN SAY IS HUNDREDS-
PETER- RATHER LARGE SITES- BUT
YOU KNOW WE HAVEN'T- DONE A SITE
ASSESSMENT TONIGHT AS FAR AS I
KNOW NOBODY'S DONE INSIDE
ASSESSMENT TO DETERMINE EXACTLY
HOW MANY UNITS- THAT COULD BE
LOCATED- IF THIS DOES NOT WORK
FOR THE DEVELOPER- AND DGS. AND
THE DMV CARE THEN AT LEAST WILL
BE NEGOTIATED- SO- I THINK BUILT
INTO THE PROCESS HERE IS SOME
SAFETY FOR ALL THE PARTIES.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG.
THANK YOU A MADAM CHAIR- THANK
YOU MISTER BLOOM FOR BRING US
FORWARD I THINK IT'S A GREAT
CONCEPT IN TERMS OF A PILOT
PROGRAM FOR THE DAY OF THE
STATE'S. BUDGET SUGGESTS
ADJOURNMENTS CONCERN FROM THE
BUILDING TRADES AS ARE ANY
UPDATES OR INFORMATION OF IT IN
MY PROVIDE ON THE LABOR
PROTECTIONS AND I DON'T HAVE AN
UPDATE THE- OPPOSITION CAME IN
RATHER LATE TO- IN THE- PROCESS
BUT- AS INDICATED- WE
IMMEDIATELY CONTACTED THE TRAITS
AND TO. BEGIN A CONVERSATION AND
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION HOPEFULLY- WORK OUT
TO- A- A FAVORABLE RESPONSE TO
THE OPPOSITION. I KNOW THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LYNN JUST A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS FROM AT FOR
ME. SO THE ANALYSIS RAISED A
COUPLE OF CONCERNS REGARDING THE
POTENTIAL REDUCED ACCESS TO DMV
SERVICES. I'M AND I THINK
SPECIFICALLY THE FACT THAT THAT
COULD. I IN FACT IMPACT
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES- YOU
KNOW MOST SIGNIFICANTLY WHO ARE.
UNABLE TO ACCESS SERVICES ONLINE
IS EASILY AS HIS SIDE HERE'S
SOME OF SOME OF US MIGHT BE ABLE
TO- CAN YOU JUST RESPOND TO SOME
OF THOSE CONCERNS AND PERHAPS.
AT PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE WITH A
BIT OF AN UPDATE IN TERMS OF
YOUR CONVERSATIONS WITH THE DMV
TO. ENSURE THAT AS WE'RE LOOKING
FOR INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES- THAT
WE- YEAH THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES DON'T HARM THE
PUBLIC. SURE FIRST I SHOULD
POINT OUT THAT- THIS PROCESS IS
NO DIFFERENT OR THE- OF THE
ULTIMATE CONSTRUCTION PROCESS
HERE IS NO DIFFERENT THAN. ANY
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT- THAT A
STATE FACILITY WOULD UNDERTAKE.
AND THE NEED TO PROVIDE SERVICES
ON AN ONGOING BASIS EXISTS AND
ALTHOUGH CIRCUMSTANCES THIS IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT IS A- IS A
NEW ISSUE IT'S ANTICIPATED. THAT
DMV TO THE EXTENT NECESSARY
WOULD PROVIDE OFF SITE SERVICES
AND- SWING SPACE NOT UNLIKE THE
SWING SPACE THAT WE FIND
OURSELVES IN NOW. AS OUR
BUILDING IS- IT IS
RECONSTRUCTED- BUT BECAUSE DMB
IS IN THE PROCESS THAT I'VE
OVERSEEN AND BUDGET SUB THREE-
OF MOVING TO A MORE ONLINE AND
KIOSK ORIENTED PROVISION OF
SERVICES WHICH IS BETTER FOR THE
PUBLIC. BETTER FOR THE STATE. OF
AS AS AS THEY MOVE INTO THAT NEW
ERA IT'S ANTICIPATED THAT SOME
OF THE SERVICES WOULD BE
PROVIDED NEARBY- IN THE KIOSK
FORMAT SOME OF THEM WOULD BE
ONLINE. AND SOME OF THE MAY NEED
TO BE LOCATED IN A PHYSICAL
FACILITY BUT THIS IS TOLL
TOTALLY WITHIN- PER. THEY WILL.
WHAT SERVICES ARE NECESSARY I'M
QUITE CERTAIN THAT THEY WOULD-
NOT DO SOMETHING THAT WOULD
DIMINISH THE SERVICES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE THEY CAN ALSO SINCE
THESE THREE. OF PROJECTS ARE
NEAR ONE ANOTHER THEY CAN
NEGOTIATE THESE LEASES IN A IN A
WAY- THAT TO A- ALLOWS FOR. A
STAGE CONSTRUCTION THEY DON'T
HAVE TO DO AND I DON'T THINK
THEY WOULD DO ALL THREE OF THESE
FACILITIES AT THE SAME TIME THEY
COULD DO ONE AFTER THE OTHER SO
THAT- THERE WAS SOME CONTINUITY.
IN SERVICES IN THE REGION
THEY'RE ALL WITHIN A RELATIVE
FEW MILES FROM ONE ANOTHER.
THANK YOU FOR THAT- AND THEN I
THINK THROUGH MY TAKE ON THIS
BILL IS THAT HI IT'S ACT IT'S
ASKING IF OUR STATE. AGENCIES
AND CITY PARTNERS I THINK TO
TAKE. FROM THERE MORE CREATIVE
AND DYNAMIC APPROACH THAN WE
OFTENTIMES SEE FROM HER
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES BUT THAT I
THINK CALIFORNIANS I'M- EXPECT
TO SEE MORE OF. I'M AND HAVE A
REASON TO EXPECT TO SEE MORE OF
SO I'M RECOGNIZING THAT IT THINK
THIS IS BEING FRAMED AS A PILOT
PROJECT I THINK ALSO
RECOGNIZING. THIS IS THE FIRST
COMMITTEE HEARING ON THIS BILL
WILL ALSO BE HEARD AND
TRANSPORTATION WHICH I DO THINK.
GIVES ARE THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
TIME TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH AT
THE BUILDING TRADES AND I TALK
THROUGH SOME OF THOSE. LATE
OBJECTIONS AND I AND WORK
THROUGH TO ENSURE THAT THE
SOLUTION INCLUDES LABOR
PROTECTIONS IN THE BILL AND YOU
KNOW WITH THAT I HOPE I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY AND
I'M- NOT RECOMMENDING. I SUPPORT
FROM THE COMMITTEE SO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE. I
THINK YOU SECRETARY IF YOU CAN
CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION. GINORMOUS I
PETRIE-NORRIS I PATTERSON
PATTERSON AYE GRAY. LACKEY NOT
VOTING LACKING NOT VOTING
MEDINA. MEDINA AYE RODRIGUEZ.
FONG I. ALL RIGHT FIVE I ZERO
AND SO THAT BILL IS OUT AND WILL
BE THROWN OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PLAN. LET'S SEE WE ONLY
HAVE WE'VE GOT WILL BY THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND THEN WE
HAVE ONE. REMAINING BELL ON FILE
. OKAY M. FIVE BEEN TOLD THAT MR
MCCARTY IS ON HIS WAY. OUT LET'S
GO AHEAD AND- DISPENSE WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE TWO
BILLS ON OUR CONSENT CALENDAR
TODAY EIGHTY TWO ONE SEVEN THREE
AND A. B. TWO EIGHT EIGHT FIVE.
FIVE WE NEED A. SECOND HOUR K.
I. GREAT ADMISSION AND SECOND
THE- FOR THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR FOR
AT AB TWO ONE SEVEN THREE AND DO
PASS AND RE REFER TO- THE
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE
FOR AB TWO EIGHT EIGHT FIVE I'M
SECRETARY IF YOU CAN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. PETRIE-NORRIS I HI
PATTERSON HI PATTERSON I GREAT
BLACKING I'VE- BLACKIE HI MEDINA
AYE MEDINA AYE RODRIGUEZ. HI
RODRIGUEZ I FONG. I AB TWO ONE
SEVEN THREE IS OKAY SIX ZERO I
AND WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN- FOR
BELIEVE THEY'RE OPEN PRESS
ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD ON AND-
MCCARTY. THIS TIME. EXACTLY YEAH
. ALL RIGHT LOOK WHAT WILL TO
OPEN.
I SEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY THANK YOU
FOR ADD PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF
OUR COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY- WE WILL BE HEARING
ABOUT- MCCARTY'S. TWO FIVE NINE
TWO. THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR ARE FIRST AND FOREMOST-
I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS ONE OF THE LEADING
CONTRIBUTORS TO THE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS IS A LACK
OF HOUSING SUPPLY CALIFORNIA'S
ADDED THREE POINT TWO TIMES MORE
PEOPLE THAT HOUSING IN THE LAST
TEN YEARS. HOW MANY STATE LOT OF
CORPORATE THE BENEFITS OF THE
EXECUTIVE BOARD WILL FACILITATE
THE IDENTIFICATION STATE
BUILDING FRIEDMAN FREED UP BY
THE STATE'S TRANSITION TO
TELEWORK THIS BILL DIRECTS DG
HAS TO DEVELOP A PLAN TO
TRANSITION ON JULY STATE
BUILDINGS- HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE HAVE THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO- ROSTER.
BUCKLEY THANK YOU. HELLO MISTER
BUCKLEY GOOD MORNING MANCHURIAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU MY NAME IS
ROSS BARKLEY ON BEHALF OF. A
SACRAMENTO SACRAMENTO MAYOR
DARRELL STEINBERG- THE MAYOR'S
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND
THANKS TO SUMMER FOR BRING
FORWARD THIS LEGISLATION THE
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES TO
REPAIR STREAMLINED PLAN. AT TO
TRANSITION UNDER YOU LIE STATE
BUILDINGS THE STATE SURPLUS
LANDS INTO HOUSING OF WHICH 20%
MUST BE AFFORDABLE. AS THE
STATE'S AS A HOMES THE STATE
CAPITAL THE C. OF SACRAMENTO HAS
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER. OF STATE
OWNED PROPERTIES THAT'S THIS
LEGISLATION CREATES. AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THESE UNDER
UTILIZED STATE BUILDINGS AND
LANCE WE TRANSITIONED INTO
CRITICAL HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS TO
HELP OUR CITY IN THE REGION AT
LARGE ME ITS HOUSING NEEDS. THE
BILL PROVIDES IMPORTANT NEXT
STEP TO ENSURE THESE BUILDINGS
AND STATE LANDS CONTINUE TO
AFFECT CALIFORNIA ADDRESS OUR
HOUSING SHORTAGE AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS FOR THESE REASONS THE
MAYOR. BASS STRONGLY. SUPPORTS
AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY TWO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I MISS BURKE
THAT IS YOUR ONLY PRIMARY
WITNESS CORRECT I BELIEVE SO-
ARE THERE AND I DON'T BELIEVE WE
HAVE ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE. ARE
THERE ANYWITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM WISHING TO. TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. C. NINE
OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY AT
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. ARE CURRENTLY NO PURCHASE
BUT FROM THE POINT OF TIME. ANY
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. C. NINE
OPERATOR ANY WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. NOT AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT I WITH THAT WE'LL OPEN
IT UP QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WHAT IS READY
I DO HAVE A QUESTION I KNOW YOU
AND I HAVE HAVE HAD SOME OF THIS
CONVERSATION OFFLINE- SO. I AT
THE GOVERNOR ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER AT SOME TIME AGO. I
DIRECTING DGS TO- INVENTORY
SURPLUS PROPERTIES AND EVALUATE
THEIR SUITABILITY FOR ODD
FUTURE- USE AS HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS. AND I KNEW
THAT WHEN WE WERE IN
CONVERSATION YOUR VISION FOR
THIS BILL IS. MUCH DIFFERENT
THAN NOT COMPATIBLE WITH THAT
BUT BUILT ON THAT CAN YOU JUST
SPEAK TO AT THE WAYS IN WHICH
YOUR PROPOSAL. I DIFFERS FROM
THE EXISTING EXECUTIVE ORDER IN
THE WORK THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
DONE BY DGS- AND OTHER WAYS IN
WHICH- THE I GUESS THE GAPS THAT
YOU SEE THAT STILL NEED TO BE
FILLED. YEAH THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE I KNOW
MISTER GRAY DID A FABULOUS JOB
HE KNOWS MY CITY BETTER THAN I
DO SHE'S BEEN HERE TWENTY YEARS.
REALLY MERCED CASH- BUT AS YOU
AS YOU WALK AROUND DOWNTOWN
GRAND IT'S BEEN TOUGH FEW DAYS
DOWNTOWN HE DOES LACK OF PEOPLE
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF WORK SO
THE NATURE OF WORK IS CHANGING
AFTER COATED WITH REMOTE WORK
AND SO ARE CITY- AND R. MERRITT
HER CONCERN WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
THE STATE WORK FORCE. DECREASES
SO YES CALIFORNIA'S A LOT OF
EFFORTS ALREADY ON SURPLUS STATE
LANDS MOST OF THOSE ARE LOW
LEVEL VACANT LOTS BABY LOW LEVEL
BUILDINGS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MULTI STORY BUILDINGS HERE
DOWNTOWN. NOT SOLD IT MORE
DEFECTS DIFF DIFFERENT AND
DIFFICULT TO CONVERT TO
RESIDENTIAL SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW
THE CITIZEN HOTEL- CERTAIN
MISTER GRAY FIVE MEMBERS TWENTY
YEARS AGO THAT WS AN OFFICE
BUILDING OR A LOT OF LEGISLATIVE
GROUPS HAD THEIR OFFICES ABOUT
FIFTEEN TWENTY YEARS AGO IT WAS
CONVERTED. TO RESIDENTIAL ALBEIT
A HOTEL NOT NOT HOUSING AND SO
IT'S A LITTLE MORE DIFFICULT AND
JUST TURNING OVER LAND TO.
DEVELOPERS TO BUILD HOUSING IS
GOING TO BE SOME EXTRA EFFORTS
OF THIS BILL WOULD SPECIFICALLY
TASK DGS TO HELP COME UP WITH
STRATEGIES. HOW WE CAN FOCUS ON
ADAPTIVE REUSE OF THE STATE.
ASSETS THEY DON'T BECOME A JUST
A DRAG ON OUR CENTRAL CITY AND
CORPS OF GOVERNMENT AND SO ABOUT
THIS BILL GOES FOR I THINK TO
HOUSING- PREPARATIONS- COMMITTEE
I WOULD I WOULD YOU WANT TO
NARROW IT TO FOCUS ON- THE
VERTICAL- SURPLUS STATE ASSETS.
TRAFFIC AND AS NOTED THIS THIS
IS THE FIRST AT. COMMITTEE WHERE
THIS BILL IS BEING HEARD IT IS
BEING NINE REFERRED TO HOUSING
WHERE I THINK SOME OF. THAT
SPECIFICITY IN AND REFINEMENT-
YOU CAN CAN BE. INCORPORATED I'M
- AND AGAIN AS WITH- THE MEASURE
THAT WAS- THAT THE COMMITTEE.
JUST FIVE REVIEWED WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLAM THIS IS ASKING OUR
STATE AGENCIES TO TAKE A MORE
CREATIVE AND DYNAMIC APPROACH.
TO ADDRESSING THE HOUSING CRISIS
WHICH I THINK IS APPROPRIATE AND
I THINK. CALIFORNIA EXPECTS THAT
WE'RE USING OUR STATE RESOURCES
AND ASSETS AND DYNAMIC AND
CREATIVE WAYS TO FIVE. SEIZE THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE AFFORDED
TO US BY CHANGING TIMES- SO WITH
THAT. AB WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
YEAH I'D I DON'T THINK THIS IS
AN EASY ISSUE- YOU COULD GIVE
AWAY LAND FREE FOR SOME
DEVELOPER TO DO HOUSING AND-
IT'S NOT THAT EASY PAY WOULD BE
HOUSING BILLS IT'S GONNA TAKE
SOME. COOPERATION AND RESOURCES
THE GOVERNOR IN THE BUDGET HAS
PUT- I THINK TO POTS OF FIFTY
MILLION. IN THE BUDGET TO LOOK
AT THIS BUT IT DAVID REYNOLDS
NEED OTHER STRATEGIES DYNAMIC
STRATEGIES AS YOU SAY. AND SO-
THIS IS AN EFFORT TO CERTAINLY
ADDRESS THAT AND THANK YOU
ASPERA. ALL RIGHT AT SECRETARY
OF WILL YOU CALL THE ROLL THEY-
MISSION IT WE NEED A MOTION. THE
WITH THAT WOULD YOU DIVERT YOUR
ON IT OKAY GOOD WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND AYE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO IT HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. PETRIE-NORRIS I.
PATTERSON PATTERSON I GREAT.
GREAT I LACKING SORRY NO. NO
PARKING NO MEDINA. MEDINA I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE FONG AYE
FONG. AT SIX ONE THAT BILLS OUT
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY. AND THAT
LET'S GO AHEAD AND- SECRETARY
CALLED THE AT REAL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS ON THE OTHER MEASURES.
A. B. AB TWO FOUR THREE NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION.
GREAT. THIS WOULD BE AB TWO FOUR
THREE NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM. OKAY OKAY GREAT NONVOTING
. A. B. TWO ONE SEVEN THREE THAT
IS ON CONSENT. I JUST NEED TO
OPEN CAN. OKAY LET'S GO AHEAD
AND OPEN THE ROLE IN THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SECRETARY CAN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OKAY CONSENT AB
TWO ONE SEVEN THREE AND TWO
EIGHT EIGHT FIVE. AT GREAT- I.
OKAY I BELIEVE THAT CONCLUDES AT
THE BUSINESS ON OUR FILE TODAY.
WITH THAT THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.